[Music]
we are happy to be able to bring you
lots of exciting updates again this week
among them are Spider-Man 4 an upcoming
Bambi horror movie new images of the
forthcoming the last of a series as well
as a new motion poster of the upcoming
fourth season of Netflix's you also if
you want to know what many pounds of
cocaine a full-grown black bear and the
21 Jump Street creators have in common
stay tuned
many of you probably have heard of the
upcoming cocaine bear movie from 21 Jump
Street creators Chris Miller and Phil
Lord first a bizarre poster started
circulating on social media on it you
can see a black and white image of a
towering bear covered in a white
substance at first glance you might
think it's snow but in conjunction with
the catchy title cocaine bear there's no
doubt left on what it actually is in
addition the words inspired by true
events attract attention because in fact
a case occurred in the 1980s in which a
black bear was found to have consumed
several pounds of cocaine after it was
thrown from a Smuggler's vehicle that
was too heavily loaded so what at first
sounds like a crazy Raiders fever dream
turns out to be a true story that will
be humorously brought to the big screen
a first trailer was released this past
Wednesday and reveals the film's
intentional trash Factor The Hunger
Games director Elizabeth Banks has taken
over directing and in the leading roles
we can expect to see among others the
American Stars Margo Martindale and
Carrie Russell as well as Straight Outta
Compton hacker O'Shea Jackson Junior it
is also one of the very last movies in
which the late Ray Liotta will be
featured so let's see how the movie will
be received by audiences it'll be out in
theaters starting February 24 2023.
the preparations for the series premiere
of the upcoming The Last of Us series
are currently in full swing a few days
ago we got to see a new poster that
should police fans of the gaming series
as the design is very similar to that of
the game cover both protagonists are
gazing back at the viewer in front of a
post-apocalyptic setting with the vibe
being gloomy indeed many feelings of
nostalgia come up at the site especially
for those who played the game in 2013
when it was first released on the
PlayStation 3. now they get treated to a
10 episode series almost 10 years later
in general the anticipation seems to be
high and with just under six weeks to go
before the release HBO Max has released
some additional images of the characters
that we'll be making an appearance a
total of 11 characters are introduced
including Joel's daughter Sarah Ellis
Frant Riley and the popular companions
Bill and Tess in addition to Joel
lanelli hardly any other video game
adaptation is currently under as much
pressure to meet fans expectations as
The Last of Us which is mainly due to
the large fanbase and the excellently
rated first part of the video game
series in terms of story The Last of Us
revolves around the unlikely team of
Joel and Ellie Joel is a Smuggler who
one day receives the unusual assignment
of escorting the young teenager Ellie
across the United States at first the
two are very skeptical of each other but
over the course of the story they grow
into an unbeatable team and must
overcome many dangers together in
addition to the spreading fungus which
has wiped out a large part of the living
creatures and almost all humans turning
them into the undead there are also many
human threats be it deceitful Highwaymen
the ex-military or entire organizations
behind the scenes game designer Neil
druckman is involved as a producer and
Chernobyl director Craig Mason is in
charge of directing the official series
debut is January 15 2023 on HBO Max
the Spider-Man trilogy is an
unparalleled success in director John
Watts filmography the 41 year old was
significantly responsible for the
realization of the film series with Tom
Holland and if Sony officials have their
way we'll also direct the upcoming
movies in his podcast a few days ago
industry Insider Tom Smith spoke about
this very topic because apparently the
planned commitment of watts is not going
as well as expected at Sony before the
Spider-Man installment with Tom Holland
is a knee Works under top priority and
so the pressure to finally start
concrete preparations for filming is
growing the screenplay is also said to
be currently receiving special attention
but unlike the contract with Tom Holland
the one with John Watts has not been
signed yet previously the director
announced his intention to devote more
time to directing series and thus not to
focus on Spider-Man 4 for the time being
so instead watts is currently busy
creating the new Star Wars series
Skeleton Crew which has not been
completed yet and requires his full
attention thus Sony is in a quandary
because if they can't close the Watts
deal soon a delay in production could be
the immediate result on the other hand
it would also be a high risk to rely on
another director who didn't direct the
three previous films and thus has less
familiarity with the franchise also not
yet officially confirmed is Zendaya as
MJ although her commitment is surely
just a formality after all as Peter
Parker's girlfriend she is integral to
the rest of the story nevertheless it
will need some clarifying as to how she
and Peter will reunite after her memory
loss in the previous part the sequel to
Noe home will be exciting anyways since
after its ending in which the Multiverse
chaos was as good as resolved the
franchise finds itself at a kind of a
new start according to rumors a
crossover with Daredevil could be in
planning for the next film or the one
after that but there are no official
statements on the matter yet based on
the current schedule Spider-Man 4 is set
to hit theaters in the summer of 2024
but the actual date cannot be estimated
until the commitment of the director
there is further news about a Spider-Man
film that will probably not ever be
released we are talking about the fourth
Spider-Man film which wasn't planning
with director Sam Raimi and leading
actor Toby Maguire in this film The
award-winning Hollywood veteran John
Malkovich would have taken on the role
of vulture the latter is a super villain
from the Spider-Man universe and even
had a suitable costume for the film
already the proposed outfit is said to
have been intended for Malkovich and was
made for Sony by the friends of a
Twitter user who uploaded a
corresponding picture on it you can see
an elaborate outfit custom made for the
planned vulture actor which left many
fans impressed for its look the
production's progress is made
particularly clear by the image and
sparked feelings of nostalgia among many
would you have loved to have seen a
fourth Spider-Man movie starring Toby
Maguire or are you satisfied with the
Tom Holland Trilogy feel free to let us
know in the comments
with Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey and
Peter Pan Neverland nightmare two dark
and bizarre spin-offs of well-known
Disney characters will be released next
year in both cases these are horror
flicks that have nothing to do with
their original characters and are
completely separate moreover as a
family-friendly Corporation Disney is
not involved in them however how can it
be that outside filmmakers simply use
some of the most famous cartoon
characters without being hit by
copyright lawsuits from Disney the
reality is is that the copyrights to the
respective book Originals have expired
which in turn means that anyone can
adapt the world famous characters
without needing to pay for a license
this is not to be confused with Disney
films which have a particular style of
their own and are unrelated so you can't
just adapt Winnie the Pooh from Disney
Productions but have to refer to the
original book so to speak in addition to
Peter Pan and Winnie the Pooh another
equally innocent character is now
waiting for its horror makeover namely
Bambi the upcoming movie is also to be
produced by Scott Jeffrey who was
already involved in the aforementioned
Winnie the Pooh Moody as the maker
himself revealed to dread Central Bambi
will be an incredibly dark retelling of
the 1928 story with the sweet Fawn
becoming a merciless killing machine the
movie is set to be inspired by the
ritual a horror flick in which a
deer-like creature also wreaks Havoc
what are your thoughts on the odd
concept of adapting well-known book and
cartoon characters into a horror movie
and what other characters can you think
of for a fearsome horror makeover let us
know in the comments down below
in recent years Netflix has achieved
great success with you in the meantime
the Thriller series consists of three
seasons and will soon be followed by a
fourth one so it's slowly time to really
get going with the promotional phase
which is why a motion poster has now
been published it shows the main
character Joe who is now living in
London under a new identity as Professor
Jonathan Moore after the events of the
last season the background sounds
highlight the setting which is set in a
university and increase the suspense for
what the obviously not so good temperate
Professor is likely to do next Joe is
abundant for a reason as he is looking
for Marion played by taddy Gabrielle she
got involved in the incidents between
Joe and love last season and then
escaped from the United States to London
so it'll be exciting to see how the cat
and mouse game between the two ends
since Joe is obviously hot on her heels
we're looking forward to the fourth
season and hope to get a first trailer
soon the release date for the First
episodes is February 9 2023 with the
second half coming out a month later on
March 9th 2023.
that's it with the most important news
for this week if you're interested in
knowing what exciting movies you can
expect in the coming year we recommend
our latest Original Episode the best
upcoming blockbuster movies 2023. have
fun watching and see you next week
[Music]